truth is very fought over when we say
truth the biggest problem we're going to
run into is that what Society wants for
you is not what's always good for you
Society is the largest group and groups
search for consensus individuals search
for truth it is not acceptable for
society to tell you the truth on many
things there are many things Society
throws out all day long that if you are
smart and critical thinking person that
you disbelieve but you're forced to go
along with it even though deep down you
know it's not true money isn't going to
make you happy that's a society truth
that's not an individual truth look at
all the individuals trying to make money
deep down they know that yes money will
get rid of a lot of sources of
unhappiness and at least put it to the
point where happiness is then under my
control it's my choice as opposed to
being inflicted upon me externally that
is just one of a billion lies Society
tells you another lifestyle he tells you
is that you send your kids to school for
Education no they get an hour a day of
Education they get indoctrination they
get taught at the speed of the slowest
student they get taught mostly subjects
that are irrelevant or obsolete
education is a combination of a small
bit of Education a large dose of
socialization a large dose of compliance
training a massive dose of babysitting
which is helpful for parents who can't
take care of the kids at home also it
keeps young troublemakers off the
streets especially at the teenage level
who might be going out and committing
crime and causing problems or getting in
trouble so school does a lot of things
but education is just a very tiny piece
of it as all the homeschooling stats
clearly show and even the unschooling
stats are starting to show Society does
not just tell you things that are false
it programs you to beat yourself up when
you cross one of these boundaries when
you transgress against society's truths
the classic example of that is guilt
guilt is society's voice speaking in
your head guilt is society programming
you so effectively that you are your own
warden so truth seeking is a very hard
business because you essentially have to
with deep conviction understand 10
things that you are told or wrong all
day long
now let's hear Peter Thiel on the truth
about competition we've been taught that
um the losers are the people who are bad
at competing so the losers the people
who don't make the high school swim team
or whose grades aren't quite good enough
to get into the right grad school or or
whatever the case may be and I would
suggest that something very different is
the case where very often
um you know when you compete too
intensely you've lost sight of the
important things and um and you end up
working on the wrong kinds of things so
that so that it is true that competition
makes you better at that which you're
competing on but it always comes at this
terribly high price of focusing too much
on the people who are immediately around
you and um and not asking some questions
about what's more valuable meaningful or
important uh to try and do the sort of
the autobiographical version of this was
that you know I was sort of on this
hypertracked uh competitive uh sort of
things that you know teenager on 20
something
um where you know it's 8th grade Junior
High School yearbook one of my friends
and I was like I know you're going to go
to Stanford in four years four years
later I got into Stanford I went to
Stanford Stanford Law School uh ended up
at a big law firm in in New York and it
was one of these places where from the
outside everybody was trying to get in
on the inside everybody was trying to
get out
um when when when when when you left
after uh seven months and three days
um when I left after seven months and
three days one of the people down the
hall for me said you know it's really
reassuring to see you leave I had no
idea you could Escape from Alcatraz
which of course of course all you had to
do was go out the front door and not
come back but psychologically this was
this was a very uh a very tricky thing
for people to do because so much of
their sense of self-worth their sense of
identity was wrapped up in um in winning
these uh these competitions and beating
the people around them you know the the
word uh the word ready in the time of
Shakespeare the word ape meant both
primate and to imitate and uh there is
something very deeply in The Human
Condition it's how we learn things from
other people how language gets
transmitted it's how culture gets
transmitted but it also can lead us very
astray when we sort of blindly copy the
people around us where uh that's what
leads to herd-like behavior The Madness
of crowds lemming like sheep like uh
behavior that leads to all the sort of
crazy bubbles people participate in and
I think uh you know I think there is
sort of the somewhat strange phenomenon
in Silicon Valley where so many of the
successful companies seem to have been
started by people who are suffering from
a mild form of Asperger's and um and I
think we always need to turn this around
as a critique of our broader Society
what is it about a society where anyone
who does not have Asperger's is at a
disadvantage because they are talked out
of their original interesting ideas
before they're even fully formed and
they sort of sense oh that's a little
bit too weird people are looking at me
funny I better do something a little bit
more conventional I think I will just
open that restaurant after all and uh
and I think this is a this sort of is a
is a dynamic that we always have to have
to try to try to resist really hard
now let's hear chamat palihapitia on the
truth about mistakes
in terms of your mistakes Society tells
you don't make them because we will
judge you and we will look down on you
and I think the really successful people
realize that actually no
it's the cycle time of mistakes that
gets you to success
because your error rate will diminish
the more mistakes that you make You
observe them you figure out where it's
coming from is it a psychological thing
is it a you know cognitive thing and
then you fix it
so the implied thing there is that
there's a
uh in in business and investing in poker
and dating in life is that there's this
platonic GTO Game Theory optimal thing
out there and so when you say mistakes
you're always comparing to that optimal
path you could have taken I think uh
slightly different I would say mistake
is maybe a bad proxy but it's the best
proxy I have for learning
but I'm using the language of what
Society tells you sure got it Society
tells you that when you try something
and it doesn't work it's a mistake
so I just use that word because it's the
word that resonates most with most
people got it the real thing that it is
is learning yeah it's like in neural
networks it's lost the neural network
it's lost exactly uh yeah right so
you're using the mistake that is most uh
the the word that is the most
understandable especially by the way
people experience it I guess most of
life is a sequence of mistakes the
problem is when you use the word mistake
and you think about mistakes it actually
has the
counterproductive effect of you becoming
conservative in is just being risk
averse
so that if you folk if you re if you
flip it and say try to maximize the
number of successes somehow that leads
you to take more risk
um mistake scares people
I think mistakes scare people because
Society likes
these very simplified boundaries of who
is winning and who is losing
and they want to reward
people who make traditional choices
and succeed
but the thing is what's so
corrosive about that
is that they're actually not even being
put in a position to actually make a
quote-unquote mistake and fail so I'll
give you if you look at like getting
into an elite school
right Society rewards you for being in
the Ivy Leagues
in a way that you know in my opinion
incorrectly doesn't reward you for being
in a non-ivy league School
there's a certain level of status and
presumption of intellect and capability
that comes with being there
um but that system doesn't really have a
counterfactual because it's not as if
you both go to MIT and Ohio State
and then we can see two versions of Lex
Friedman so that we can figure out that
The Jig Is up and there was no
difference
right and so instead it reinforces this
idea that there is no uh truth-seeking
function there is no way to actually
make this thing whole
and so it tells you you have to get in
here and if you don't your life is over
you've made a huge mistake
now let's hear monish babri on the truth
about copying from the work of other
people
so what I found is
I found that cloning
is incredibly powerful
because so few people are willing to do
it right they're just not willing to go
there and so there's a number of facets
to cloning okay so what I try to do is
anytime I saw people in the industry or
outside the industry do anything that
impressed me or made me look up and say
oh that's something good and all that I
remember like for example one time I got
a letter from my law firm in this big
brown manila envelope and the label they
had used was a very nice elegant label
large label
firm named written nicely and it was
larger than most labels I had seen
and I cloned that I said you know what
we'll do whenever we send out stuff
we're going to use this large table and
I've used it all the companies from
Dental now okay so that's an example of
I've continued to look for small things
big things that I can clone
so cloning is a very powerful idea
if you Embrace cloning you will get a
massive Edge on your fellow peers and
humans
and people will look down on it and
that's okay we have no shame we are
Shameless
and I think it would be quite foolhardy
to not ride on the shoulders of giants I
think a lot of smart people many of them
dead
have
done a lot of heavy lifting and to try
to sit down and create everything by
yourself
nobody is that smart reflections
passage from Gustav levonne the masses
have never thirsted after truth they
turn aside from evidence that is not to
their taste preferring to defy error if
error seduced them
whoever can supply them with Illusions
is easily their Master whoever attempts
to destroy their Illusions is always
their victim quote from George Orwell
there was truth and there was untruth
and if you clung to the truth even
against the whole world you were not mad
quote from Leonardo da Vinci the truth
of things is the chief nutrient of
superior intellects
the truth from Peter thielen competition
might seem like it conflicts with the
truth from Manish babri on copying good
practices from other people but I think
they don't conflict because what Peter
Silo poses is pursuing a competitive
goal whereas munish babri is only in
favor of copying other people's best
practices when it makes sense for you to
do it so Peter is talking about copying
and competing over goals which is the
end whereas monish is talking about
copying practices and methodologies
which are just means of an end also the
kind of copying that Peter talks about
is driven by the ship-like behavior that
is common in humans as explained by
social epistemology
whereas the kind of copying that monish
talks about is driven by independent
thinking from the individual on what
makes sense to him to incorporate into
his work and personal goals
on mistakes I think that a big part of
that avoidance of mistakes and risk
aversion comes from the school system
nasimta lab argues on his book
anti-fragile that being right or wrong
is fundamentally different when we're
talking about papers or schools compared
to the real world what happens in
Academia or the school system is that
you normally need to be right at least
slightly more than wrong whereas in the
real world which runs under a power law
distribution of events we have
asymmetries going on let's take the
example of Entrepreneurship in
entrepreneurship you can be wrong most
of the time as long as each individual
mistake is inconsequential and when you
are right the win is massively
consequential so in the real world is
not about the relative proportion of
mistakes and wins it's about the
consequential magnitude of those
mistakes and wins so that's all for
today's nuggets and if you also want to
get the best nuggets from books I
recommend you to check out short form
which is a platform that I personally
love using because I can learn from many
books in a super efficient way surephone
is not sponsoring this video but I do
have an affiliate link which is
surefun.com speaking nuggets and you can
use it to get a 5 day free trial on a 20
discount on the annual subscription